[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's one of our favorites adam lefko tnt
inside the nba he hosts on tuesday night
of course the lefko show on bleacher
report
um if i said you paulie just or satan
just asked this you could have kevin
durant's career steph curry's career up
until this point
knowing what you know
whose career would you take
good question paulie
uh of the two careers i would go with
steph
um
i know that kd hit two game win or two
series defining shots in the finals
but for me
when i hear
every kid is outside wanting to shoot
threes like steph and i hear he's
inarguably the number one shooter of all
time
to me
that's why i want to have steph's career
and
i think i also get the davidson years
which man if nil was around now can you
imagine what steph curry will be pulling
in
uh so i'm gonna go steph what do you
think dan i would do steph for the
reasons you brought up that his place in
history is secure because he did win uh
mvp unanimous
um
and he changed the game kevin durant is
going to be remembered as one of the
great
players of all time scorers of all time
there's only one greatest shooter of all
time usually you can't have it you know
made out to be singular it's like
there's a group of guys who are the
greatest shooters well it's like there's
no arg even the greatest shooters can't
argue steph curry is the greatest
shooter of all time yeah reggie miller
just kind of gets out of the way and
he's like he's the guy right
yeah
just like kind of stands back um i i
also think too
uh the way that he started his career
he's become like this lovable guy
because he started off so slow with the
injuries and then when you add to that
fact um that i just look at the humans
themselves and who seems to be much more
happy with their current standing and
just looking at the humans
kevin seems to be constantly arguing
with his standing while stephen curry is
playing golf on his off days and
seemingly doesn't care about legacy and
the guys that don't care about legacy
are the guys that are comfortable with
their legacy and so just reading the
humans
do you think kevin durant will ever
admit that he made a mistake leaving
golden state
do you so
do you think he made a mistake is the
question because
i think that
i'll say this i think it was a mistake
to go there in the first place but
you go there
you're having fun
you're winning
yeah
but you know he wants to get credit
to starting his own dynasty or whatever
it is but
to me you get to play and you're having
fun
and and and i think draymond had a point
where it's like you know hey
he he shouldn't have left
i i definitely so
there's i've learned that i have two
takes that i don't think we're crazy
takes but apparently they're hot takes i
have no issue with decision that lebron
did like i've never understood why that
was an issue and two if i was kevin
durant i would have gone to the warriors
too and everyone loves to say i would
have never done it but
if if a team has the salary cap and it's
it's like hey would you like to be the
ceo of amazon a co-ceo next to jeff
bezos and it's like yeah that sounds
amazing let's do it um i i look at kevin
durant to forge his own path to come to
the east coast to be around his business
partners we don't fault lebron for
wanting to go to la for all of his
business ventures uh and to start his
own path i think that kd's issue
is that he picked the wrong running mate
is that he looked around and said it'd
be really fun to do it with kyrie and i
think if it was someone other than kyrie
like kawhi said i want to do this with
paul george and we'll see how that turns
out next year but
what it was choosing his partner that i
think was the mistake but clearly going
to the nets with the roster they had
last year and the run they were making
last year and how close they were to be
in the bucks last year the narrative
would be so different today if they get
by milwaukee
my problem with durant going to golden
state was
you had them you were going to beat them
and and to me
i know it would be tough to play with
russell westbrook i get that and that
might be a little bit bigger of a story
attached to this
but michael jordan i don't think would
go we can't beat the pistons i'm going
to join the pistons
if he did that and he was and it was now
we'd be like you got to be kidding me
like you want to take down the team
that's there in front of you
i get that i just think that in with
free agency today like i felt like
scottie pippen was making eight dollars
back then like if this is a i think it's
very interesting this finals matchup
because both were built through the
draft and they were able to do to build
all this depth because of the draft um
but kevin durant sat there and welcomed
all teams to come in and make him the
pitch and
boston and golden state and all that but
uh there's definitely a generational gap
and i'm not calling you old but i'm
calling you out
you old man
um that that i think um
with with this younger generation dan
you built kevin durant to make this
decision
talking about legacy and having
sportscenter conversations about well if
you don't want to ring where do you
stand and then he goes and he's like
well i can win two with them and we can
be one of the greatest teams of all time
like you make a list
those warriors teams have to be in the
top ten
and then we're gonna say that it was a
mistake for him doing it i just i feel
like we created this monster and then
we're like can you believe that monster
that's my only one well
and mistake might be mischaracterizing
what you know that that decision to do
it i wanted him to stay there because he
was going to take them down if they
delivered like they were supposed to
they were going to be golden state
lebron couldn't get anybody to go to
cleveland
nobody wanted to play there and so he
said okay you guys keep saying i gotta
win titles if i'm gonna be considered
the the king or the greatest right and
he went to miami i didn't have a problem
with him going to miami he tried to get
chris bosh to go to cleveland like
nobody wanted to even stop there to you
know change flights
so
on the decision
why does jim gray catch no flack for
asking 97 questions and organizing that
entire thing and like people always
blame the athletes for the media and i
just i don't understand why lebron's the
villain and jim gray is not the villain
can you i know you're a big jim breaker
well the problem is
the way this was set up the mother ship
dragged it out too long
that's the problem
if if they didn't drag it out if you
would have started and i and i've talked
to management about this since then
in fact after it happened in fact i know
who was producing and i know the whole
you know background here
and i i would have just said
make the decision
have reaction from the players who are
going to play with like you could set it
up in a way that it wasn't going to be
like bring out a representative from the
boys and girls club to accept the one
million dollar check but jim asked 85
questions because they had him drag it
out
okay i don't think jim another guy
defending jimmy
i don't have to defend jim gray but
they said let's drag this out and i kept
thinking
if i was in jim's position i would have
run out of questions
i i just wouldn't
well when you're talking about biting
your nails then i went oh my god now
we're doing manny petty's here no no no
you know i think people had a problem
with lebron
when he said he's taking his talents to
south beach instead of saying i'm i'm
joining the miami heat
look he's people don't like lebron
invading their michael jordan
stratosphere like how dare you michael
would never do that no no he would go
gamble in the middle of the night during
the playoffs or you know show up with
the flu
in quotation marks there's no social
media back then could you imagine
i
there are so many aspects of that like
when we all got a chance during
quarantine to watch the last dance and
to think of all of those stories that if
there was social media rodman in vegas
with carmen elektra during the finals
like can you imagine
tmz like updating us on like where he is
tonight oh would have been incredible he
and to go to your coach and say i need
two days off
and phil gives him two days off to go to
vegas remember johnny manziel when he
would go to vegas and then now granted
he wasn't winning anything but rodney
needed two days off to go to vegas
speaking of not winning anything great
time to talk about the emmys
um too soon
i don't know if you guys know but the
tuesday show not the thursday show the
legends tuesday show one outstanding
interactive experience
for the that's a new category that's a
new category
it might be but we've wanted two years
in a row
and i'll tell you what
when do we start having the dynasty
conversation about interacting hey guys
how about a round of applause for adam
let's go
back to back yeah
uh not to take credit but i will
who helped you be a better host who gave
you some
talking points you know it's funny i was
talking to uh brian curtis of the ringer
yeah and
he was asking me you know like what do i
compare a host to and i brought up you
because i have to give credit where
credit is due about point guards
i'm getting emotional and i've realized
um that i'm i think i'm rondo i think
i'm young rondo with those celtics teams
i think that's my conf
so you can't shoot
not yet
no
you wouldn't be a better shooter than
rondo
i don't know damn
i just want to say that i appreciate and
that i dedicate my entire career to you
and you know what we are forever linked
yeah
um i just can't wait to see how this
blossoms um
it's just so big
i'm not actually crying i'm like
battling covet right now oh you
well i'm happy for you
you know i'm excited for this final
series that we get
uh i think that i've
officially made my pick i'm going boston
i came on your show
after boston beat brooklyn and i said
two things i said ime udoka
is going to be the next great coach for
the next decade in the nba and i think
boston is going to the finals
and
i doubted myself for a little bit
but now i i think that this is going to
be their year i think the size that they
have overall
i think that the the match-ups that they
can throw out there on golden state
and when i hear people picking golden
state their main reason is experience
and i'm looking at a boston team that
just stomped kevin durant
that outlasted giannis in a seven game
series and beat them twice the chance to
win and then one in miami
and i look at what golden state went
through and i just think this year
boston's had a tougher run and i think
it prepares them for this series i think
boston's winning it then i know that you
like to pat yourself on the back by
picking a team when they were already in
the playoffs but
if i hit the wayback machine i'll go
back to the start of the season when i
said golden state would win the title
and face and said that they would face
the miami heat in the nba finals
so also understand this and i know
you're just starting out in the business
but i've been around a long time
okay
like i got to see wilt chamberlain in
person and jerry west in person like i
got to be around the game for i don't
know 50 years or so
um
boston went through a basically
one-dimensional milwaukee team
they went through a one-dimensional
miami heat team
you can make the argument a
one-dimensional brooklyn team with kevin
durant now you go against a golden state
team that has three or four guys who can
get you
at least 20 points in a game so your
defensive philosophy is a little bit
different because now it's not the
experience to me it's the balance that
they have there
and we're just maybe seeing klay
thompson coming back into the old klay
thompson forum so just want to let you
know this is just me helping you
and making you a better person so next
year when you do the interactive
experience or whatever that was that you
guys want on tnt
yeah
you can thank me again man that was a
gut punch jerry west
and wiltshire
you're killing me you're literally
handling me
that was good just the way that you the
way that you smacked me in the face and
then said i'm here for you was really
well done it's like a dog that slaps you
another dog in the face with its tail
that's what it is like i'm leaving and i
just
i smacked you that's all and then i
walked away do you think you could help
me repair my relationship
with jerry west because i still don't
think that he likes me from our ultimate
draft session
uh
let's put it this way if jerry doesn't
like you i'm not changing jerry's
opinion yeah yeah you're uh you're not
exactly winning time uh just want to say
well done yeah okay well i'm going to
feel better all right i'll find my own
way
i'm going to send him a fruit basket and
once again about a round of applause for
uh adam lefkow
and tnt interactive yeah correct
yeah lefko calls himself better than
ernie johnson yes dirk yeah you better
stop i like it ernie johnson who
well i suck on this emmy
what what wow
what
that's what i heard that's adam lefkow
he won an emmy and we didn't